And in fact, actually let's get right into
Reddit Reddit threads, because one of them
we're going to dig into in detail on the bonus
show. You can join The David Pakman Show sub
Reddit at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit.
Nearly 30000 of our viewers have. And the
discussions happening there are compelling
and interesting and respectful, importantly,
to say the least, couple of posts I want to
signal a user named Joakim Rafie says, Why
does Pakman keep making misleading statements
about the wall in his video? Jen Psaki Soki.
Jen Psaki destroys Trump in 48 seconds. At
32 seconds, Pakman says now it's really important
to remember that even though Donald Trump
didn't build the wall during his presidency,
he would regularly claim that he built it
and that the imaginary wall was responsible
for record low dotcom undocumented crossing.
This is wrong, and it isn't the first time
Pakman said stuff like this. The wiki page
says the U.S. built new barriers along four
hundred and fifty five miles, forty nine miles
of which previously had no barrier going on
to say. You can believe, as I do, Trump is
a scumbag and it's a good thing he's gone.
But why is Pacman painting himself into a
corner on this topic, guys? Trump promised
to build a wall across the entire U.S. Mexico
border by the end of his first term. That
that was the promise, Trump added. Forty nine
miles, OK, if adding forty nine miles to a
barrier to a border that's 2000 miles, Cowan
says building the wall. Then I have a bridge
to sell you. If this is your critique of the
program, this is probably not the show for
you, but very, very strange allegations. Another
post from Rico Reckless says, Are the Cuomo
allegations intended to distract from the
nursing home scandal? Or are the Democrats
and establishment using Cuomo as the scapegoat
now that Biden is in office and there's no
longer a shot at Cuomo running against Trump?
I don't. The second part, I think, is a no.
And I don't think anyone is organized enough,
nor is it clear to me that pushing sexual
assault allegations against Cuomo helps him
by distracting from the nursing home scandal.
It's just not clear to me at all. The right,
in fact, has seized more on the on the sexual
assault scandal, even though arguably it's
it's not better for Cuomo that the right sees
on that. So it's very nebulous to me that
this would be some kind of strategy. I think
to me it's more what was mentioned in the
comment, which is when it rains, it pours
and that it's just things I think a lot of
different things coming out against Andrew
Cuomo. I have no reason to think, nor have
I seen evidence that the Democratic Party
is organized enough to say, oh, that the nursing
home thing is bad. Let's now bring to the
forefront sexual assault allegations to take
attention away from that. I think both are
potentially hugely damaging to Cuomo. And
we'll just have to wait and see. And then
also interest on the sub Reddit about our
former I don't know if he's a former friend
of the show. He's been on the show. Milo Yiannopoulos
is now declaring that he is gay. He believes
that he has successfully gone through conversion
therapy and is no longer a gay man. If you
don't know who Milo monopolizes, congratulations.
I actually envy you. But we have dealt with
a lot of these ex gay advocates on the show
in the past. And we know Milo. So we're going
to talk about this more extensively on the
bonus show. But yes, I am aware of the Milo
quiting homosexuality story, and I do have
a lot to say about it, partially because we've
had exchanges with Milo and in part because
we've also talked to a lot of the people that
advocate for and even do supposedly ex gay
conversion therapy, wacky, dangerous stuff.
To be clear. We'll talk about that more on
the bonus show, but feel free to join the
discussion on the sub. Read it at David Pakman
dot com. Slash r e d d i t.